hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today Manson
question from Jeffrey who's one of our
newer forum members and he wrote in with
a question it's a pretty long lens I'm
just going to kind of summarize so he's
a blacksmith and he works for a company
that does really high-end work and he
made a partnership deal with the
magazine where he created a bronze
statue of a really famous football coach
that ran in the magazine and promoted
the business and he told his boss at the
company and worked out a sales
commission for it so that every new sale
that came in through the magazine he
made a certain percentage off the boss
at first in think was going to work but
it ended up having a lot of success and
now the boss wants him to be more
involved in the sales and marketing and
he's saying I don't really know what to
do because I'm just a blacksmith iron
worker and wanted some advice on how to
effectively sales you sales and
marketing to grow this business so
thanks to the question Jeffry
congratulations on the success that it's
had it's great to see a lot of people
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
these strategies and doing a lot of
failing before they reach some success
so it's great that you you hit it on
your first one in terms of growing this
this business up one of the biggest ways
to and fastest ways to grow your
business is through partnerships and
it's something that you've already done
and it's worked here in this case and I
look for ways to replicate that success
and so basically through partnerships
you're finding somebody who already has
the audience that you're looking for
find some kind of way to partner up with
them and have them promote you to their
audience in return for you than a
percentage or some other kind of way
that you think would work out so in your
example you partner up with the magazine
and you didn't pay them anything but you
had to create the statue which costs you
know time and effort and materials are
presumed to make this thing but in
return they then promoted you to their
audience and the audience came in and
bought from your company so that's a
great partnership strategy and a such a
fast way to grow business because they
already have an established market and
so I try to find other examples like
that it could be companies it could be
Media find people who are already
catering to your target audience they
already have your customers they're not
doing the same thing that you do right
they're not they're not doing the the
Iron working that you're doing or the
bronze working but they have your target
audience they do something else that
sell it to your same market and find a
way to partner up with them give them
something of value could either be a
percentage of the commission that you're
making or could be something else that
you do either just offering to promote
them if they promote you or you give
them something like you give them the
statue just like you did with the
magazine find something that you can do
to help them and give them an incentive
to want to promote you and then they
have that incentive they go and they do
it and they hopefully bring in new
customers for you so I try to find other
opportunities maybe you do 12 months you
got your magazine as one and then look
for other opportunities to be able to go
out and do the exact same thing and if
you're really good at creating the
statues then that might be what you do
you might find 12 partners you do one a
month and you can come back and repeat
same things like that magazine that you
did it with it doesn't have to be only
one time thing you come back to them in
six months or in a year and do it all
over again because they'll have new
readers and the readers who read it last
time may not have seen it and so it
could also be a good reminder maybe they
weren't ready to buy at that time now
they're ready to buy now so if it worked
out well with that magazine keep them on
board and do it again again in six
months or a year but don't just do it as
kind of a one-time thing and then find
other partners and if you do one per
month with different publications or
partners where there's an opportunity
for them to promote you and and you can
help them by creating the statue that
could be a great way to focus on what
you're really good eye which is creating
you know the statues and they focus on
you know helping promote you to their
audience which they can be you know
hopefully really good at to their
business you'll find that some are
really good and some aren't really good
so this magazine was a winner that's
awesome you want to find you know love
and other winners and you can just
repeat through every year some you know
won't be that successful and so you you
know you don't use them again the next
time around and the ones who are really
good you stick with and something that's
really specific like what you do and you
said your boss does really really high
in staircases
you probably won't have too many awesome
potential partners so even if you find
five or six like if you had six partners
and you just did it twice here with each
partner that could be enough to drive a
lot of new business to your company so
that's where I would start you've
already had some proof of success you
can use as a case study to go and talk
to other companies and it allows you to
focus on what you're really good at
which is creating the actual bronze
statues and hopefully you get a nice
good commission check out of it so
thanks for the question you have to be
welcome to the forums it's great to have
you as a member and for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below I love seeing
those come in and if you have a comment
about this video or question for your
own company or business feel free to
leave it in the comment section below I
always read those they always applied so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode
you